تغطيه المباشره متواصله لاثار زلزال
العنيف والمدمر الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا ووصلت
دعاياته الى شمال سوريا اعداد القتلى في
ارتفاع مستمر فيما تتواصل عمليه الانقاذ
بحثا عن ناجين الزلزال مشاهدينا بلغت قوته
7.8 درجات على مقياس رختر وفيما تحدثت
التسلطات التركيه عن انهيار 1700 مبنى في
عشر ولايات تبقى الارقام مجهوله في سوريا
اذا على الجانب السوري ضرب الزلزال
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها المعارضه
والمقتضى بنحو اربعه ملايين سوري نزحوا من
مناطق اخرى من البلاد بسبب الحرب الاهليه
مواصل العربيه ذكر ان الوضع الانساني في
شمال سوريا ماساوي بسبب نقص الامكانات وان
المواصفات الطبيه في شمال سوريا غير قادره
على التعامل مع نوعيه الاصابات
الجهه الفاعله في شمال سوريا اعلنت
المنطقه منطقه من كوبا وقال نشيطون في
مناطق المعارضه السوريه ان عائلات باكملها
محاصره تحت انقاض المباني المناره المرصد
السوري كان يتحدث عن 400 قتيل حتى الان
ومسير مجهول يواجه المئات مشيرا الى ان 58
قريه وبلده في شمال سوريا شهدت انهيارات
كليه او جزئيه للمباني وان حجم كارثه
الزلزال يفوق الامكانات المتوفره في شمال
سوريا